Diese Studie macht wirklich Gänsehaut.
Laut einem internationalen Forschungsteam
stehen unsere Ökosysteme kurz vor einem katastrophalen
Zusammenbruch.
Demnach wird es in 100 Jahren gar keine Insekten
mehr auf der Erde geben - und das bedeutet
langfristig wohl das Ende für uns alle.
In diesem Zusammenhang wird oft auch das sechste
Massensterben genannt.
Auslöser dafür sind wir Menschen.
Warum wir wie ein heftiger Asteroideeinschlag
sind: Clixoom Science & Fiction, hier gibt
es täglich spannende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts, herzlich willkommen!
Erstmal zum Anfang möchte ich mich ins Zeug
legen für alle Heldinnen und Helden, die
aufstehen gegen den Klimawandel.
Denn ihr seid tatsächlich Heldinnen und Helden
im Gegensatz zu vielen vermeintlich “Erwachsenen”.
Und ich muss mich für meine Generation hier
entschuldigen, dass sie trotz eindeutiger
wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse nicht die
Konsequenzen zieht.
Und deshalb muss man euch ganz fraglos unterstützen.
Denn hier geht es nicht um Politik, was alle
Nationen ja auch bestätigen.
Sie sind sich ja einer Meinung, dass hier
gehandelt werden muss, aber sie tun es nicht,
beziehungsweise zu langsam, und erfüllen
nicht mal ihre eigenen Zusagen, so wie die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die unter anderem
Arbeitsplätze als Grund angibt, euch oder
eure Nachkommen umzubringen.
Da muss man schon sagen, dass das schäbig
ist.
Ich kann also nur jeden dazu auffordern am
15.
März auf die weltweite Demo in eurer Stadt
zu gehen und den Politikerinnen und Politikern
zu zeigen, dass sie sich zu Mördern machen,
wenn sie nicht zumindest ihre eigenen Beschlüsse
umsetzen.
Ihr habt recht Heldinnen und Helden!
ich bin dabei!
Und ihr auch!
Zum Thema: Schon einige frühere Studien hatten
eindeutige Hinweise darauf gegeben, dass es
immer weniger Insekten gibt - vor allem auch
in Deutschland.
Schuld daran sind unter anderem der starke
Einsatz von Pestiziden, die intensive Landwirtschaft
und der Klimawandel.
Doch eine aktuelle Studie bringt es jetzt
knallhart auf den Tisch: Demnach ist das Insektensterben
ein gigantisches Problem - und zwar WELTWEIT!
Die Gesamtmasse aller Insekten auf der Erde
sinkt demnach jährlich um 2,5 Prozent - so
war es zumindest in den letzten 25 bis 30
Jahren.
Sollte dieser Trend anhalten, hätte dies
ein katastrophales Ende.
Dazu Franciso Sanchez-Bayo, einer der beteiligten
Forscher: “In zehn Jahren werden wir ein
Viertel weniger haben, in 50 Jahren ist noch
die Hälfte übrig und in 100 Jahren werden
wir gar keine mehr haben.”
Nach Angaben der Studie ist ein die sogenannte
Extinktionsrate - der Begriff Extinktion meint
soviel wie Aussterben - achtmal höher als
bei Säugetieren, Reptilien und Vögeln.
Diese beunruhigenden Erkenntnisse beruhen
auf der Analyse von insgesamt 73 Berichten
aus der Vergangenheit, die sich bereits mit
dem Rückgang von Insekten-Populationen weltweit
beschäftigt hatten.
Die aktuelle Studie macht noch einmal ganz
klar deutlich: Das Ganze ist ein großes weltweites
Problem!
Vor allem verschiedenen Arten von Bienen sind
dabei, für immer zu verschwinden - und zwar
vor allem in Nordamerika, Dänemark und Großbritannien.
Betroffen sind aber auch Schmetterlinge und
Motten.
In England beispielsweise gab es zwischen
2000 und 2009 einen Rückgang der Schmetterlingsarten
auf landwirtschaftlich genutzten Flächen
um 58 Prozent.
Auch die Anzahl der Hummelarten ist beispielsweise
in Oklahoma von 1949 bis 2013 um die Hälfte
gesunken.
Ähnlich bei den Bienen - auch ist ein krasser
Rückgang zu verzeichnen: Waren es 1947 noch
6 Millionen Honigbienen-Kolonien in den USA,
sind es jetzt nur noch 2,5 Millionen.
Und Das Aussterben der Insekten hat weitreichende
Folgen für das gesamte Leben auf der Erde.
Die Studie spricht von einem “katastrophalen
Zusammenbruch der Ökosysteme”.
Falls das Sterben der Insekten nicht gestoppt
wird, wird dies “katastrophale Folgen sowohl
für die Ökosysteme des Planeten als auch
für das Überleben der Menschheit haben”,
so der Forscher Sanchez-Bayo.
Denn klar ist: Insekten nehmen eine enorm
wichtige Rolle ein - als Nahrung für andere
Lebewesen, als Bestäuber und außerdem als
Nährstoff-Recycler.
Ein dramatisches Problem resultiere daraus
vor allem für Vögel, Fische, Amphibien und
Reptilien, sie sich von Insekten ernähren.
Aber auch unsere Nahrungsquellen könnte durch
den Rückgang der Insekten knapp werden - schließlich
übernehmen Bienen und Schmetterlinge als
Bestäuber eine wichtige Funktion für das
Wachstum von Gemüse und Früchten.
In diesem Zusammenhang ist auch vom sogenannten
sechsten Massensterben auf der Erde die Rede.
Ein Forschungsteam von der Universität Mexiko
und der Stanford University hatte vor zwei
Jahren (2017) eine Studie veröffentlicht,
nach der 75 Prozent aller Spezies in den nächsten
Jahrhunderten von der Erde verschwinden werden.
In ihren Untersuchungen kam heraus, dass die
Populationen von insgesamt 27.600 Arten an
Vögeln, Reptilien, Amphibien und Säugetieren
kontinuierlich abnehmen.
Dazu die Studie: “Das sechste Massenaussterben
der Erde ist ernster als anfangs gedacht.
Es geht etwas Großes vor sich”.
Der Begriff sagt es schon: Auch in früheren
Zeiten gab es massives Artensterben auf der
Erde.
Die Ursachen damals waren aber Eiszeiten oder
Asteroiden-Einschläge.
Und genau das ist der große Unterschied:
An dem aktuell stattfindenden Massensterben
sind einzig und allein wir Menschen Schuld.
Wir die Menschheit verhalten uns also gerade
wie ein absolut katastrophaler riesiger Asteroideneinschlag.
Das ist wirklich schlimm!
Laut Sanchez-Bayo bewirkt vor allem eine bestimmte
Sache das Aussterben der Insekten: “Die
Hauptursache für den Rückgang ist die intensive
landwirtschaftliche Nutzung der Landschaft.
Alle Bäume und Sträucher, die normalerweise
die Felder umgeben, werden beseitigt.
Es gibt also nur noch einfache, kahle Felder,
die mit synthetischem Dünger und Pestiziden
behandelt werden”.
Vor allem die neuen Insektizide, die in den
letzten 20 Jahren entwickelt worden, seien
besonders schädlich.
Doch genau diese werden routinemäßig eingesetzt
und verbleiben dann auch in der Umwelt.
Einige Arten, wie etwa eine bestimmte Hummel-Art
in den USA, können sich anpassen.
Doch die Zunahme dieser weniger Arten könne
den Rückgang der aussterbenden Arten längst
nicht kompensieren, so die Studie.
Lediglich eine ökologische Form der Landwirtschaft
könne dem großen Insekten-Sterben noch entgegenwirken.
Auch andere Experten, die nicht an der aktuellen
Studie beteiligt waren, werten das den Rückgang
der Insekten als ein dramatisches Problem.
Doch sehen sie neben dem Einsatz der Pestizide
auch noch andere Faktoren, die dazu beitragen.
Beispielsweise seien die globale Erwärmung
und auch die Lichtverschmutzung in diesem
Kontext nicht zu unterschätzen.
Warum die Insekten sterben?
Also draufklicken und dieses Video unbedingt
ansehen!
Eine Doku vom Bayerischen Fernsehen!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!